guy so this colt brennan was my roommate
for a little bit university of colorado
he's a redshirt freshman
and we would drive together in the
freezing weather and
university of colorado during they
called um
dirty dozens and it was the way they
would weed out the the weak links
and we'd do conditioning at four in the
morning and me and him used to
heat uh my car up and then him or i
would drive
to the uh [ __ ] conditioning the
nicest kid ever the nice kid ever this
is a kid who um
he you know when you get to university
colorado it's so competitive and he was
a stud in california super stud
but when you get humbled when you get to
the university of color like division
one program
because now there's seven other guys
just like you and he had this weird
thing about him where he
always he just he had like that surface
mentality where he was just like
it'll work out man it'll work out man so
obviously he wasn't playing he was the
red shirt uh
freshman and he was the scout team
quarterback kid was talented as [ __ ]
he goes cool leaves the university of
colorado because there was other guys
that they kept putting ahead of them so
he's like that's fine i'll figure out
leaves goes goes to university of hawaii
and becomes one of the best quarterbacks
to ever ever play college football
set all the records at the university of
hawaii finished third in heisman voting
that year and then got drafted i think
like the sixth round to the washington
redskins
here's where it gets sad is um
he got in a car wreck and really [ __ ]
up his brain and was suffering from
like some brain trauma and that's where
things started to go spiraled downhill
and started doing drugs and then
you know he was in southern california
san diego and did some drugs and there's
fentanyl is laced with fentanyl
ended up killing him kills a lot super
sad story
superstar killed a lot of people yeah
tom petty
i think really yeah fentanyl did they
have fentanyl back then
no he died back in the night recently
yeah this is
not the time he died in 1989 but the
time he died for real
uh yeah i don't know i i mean they're
well
so one of the so i've talked a lot of
guys are like
security mexico you know experts and
they're talking about china
going to mexico and setting up labs and
that's where the fentanyl comes out
hotels bringing it in
and in the george floyd uh trial that
the uh well what uh what's the officer
uh chauvin chauvin whatever one of the
things
was when he had pills or he got busted
for a traffic stop or something
earlier a year earlier something like
that we had pills but they were marked
like as as painkillers but there were
bootleg
like fentanyl stuff i don't think i
don't know if people know what they're
taking
no i don't think they're just taking
fentanyl they're no they don't mean to
that's that's like pain yeah that's how
i think they're taking painkillers and
the knockoffs are so good now that
nobody knows knockoff is fentanyl well
they think they're getting like some
form of cocaine something like that but
it's so strong because
there's fentanyl in it because it's
cheaper or they lace it with it so
that's how mac miller
oh yeah isn't it he thought he was
taking his normal dosage you know
because he was a drug addict
and he there was actually a ton of
fentanyl in it and he ended up dying so
the
but what they did the lapd they arrested
the kid who sold him
that drug and then also the kid where he
got it from so two people arrested in
that death damn well
i thought they late i thought they
actually laced uh their cocaine right
they laced yeah yeah they realized
they're called canada
was a downer why would you lace it with
[ __ ] i don't know
but like i i i just remember reading the
transcripts he was like he ordered women
drugs and like booze and then didn't
realize like exactly what brandon said
he didn't realize it
od and then yeah the guy got right and
there's you know i watch intervention
all the time there's they're on season
whatever 19 or some [ __ ]
but uh there's people on there who are
addicts and they take like straight
fentanyl their tolerance is
so high they're taking straight fentanyl
to the [ __ ] bloodstream yeah
yeah it's sad it's it's it's really true
it doesn't really work out sad world
everyone should just kill themselves at
30.
it never works out we all end up like
jan michael vincent you know
what else you guys you know
oh really the fba fbi release following
suspicion raised about
kurt cobain's 1994 death so they have to
release the
the files all the reports and in the
reports you find out that there's
tons of people and evidence that they're
like dude he didn't commit suicide
like you guys got to do a better job wow
so the fbi is now releasing that
saying like wait so that may also
include a letter from the official work
in the us
office of congressional and public
affairs run the letter sent
to the us attorney general janet reno in
2000
so everyone kept saying like you gotta
look more into this like you didn't do
your job you just say suicide and you
get the [ __ ] out but you don't look at
the crime scene
yeah that gun does not make sense
because like how long it was
and for him yeah they've had experts
look at and like it just doesn't like
that gun's too
long and then also like he couldn't even
do it with his foot he couldn't do it
but also the amount of
meth that was or heroin that was in his
body they said he he couldn't function
to shoot the gun
there's no way well you have that much
hair on your body
you're not picking up a gun you wouldn't
be able to sit down on the chair well i
think did it courtney yeah
really and the letter they think you
know yeah there's a gun there it is
so here's the the longest gun in the
world here's the here's the thing
although the guy holding the gun looks
exactly like a guy who would be holding
there
they probably had a short jewish guy and
they went off i was going to swap him
out with the dude who looks like he
came here with this guy get the guy get
the guy who drinks black rifle coffee
he's dead behind the eyes that guy looks
like he went out to his truck to go get
a gun
yeah i didn't walk away i have the exact
same one in my chevy bag here if you
want me to get it
he takes his gun and his hair very
seriously do you think
they stage it a little like they direct
it like hey bob not so intense
at this time first off you're freaking
me out like did you use that gun on me
i'm just taking a picture
this guy looks like he's hell-bent on
using that gun
in the workplace yeah yeah not hunting
that kind of car
doc man if you watch it though and you
get a real they have a private
investigator go through the whole scene
you're like holy [ __ ] this is
but let me circle back to the jeopardy
guy
flashing the white it doesn't help your
case when you
look like the dude and kurt cobain
pouting all the time
yeah looking suicidal all the time yeah
when he does when when when he does
commit suicide or doesn't we just go
app knew it the perfect candidate that's
what the cops
like suicide i mean he he did have the
stomach issues
so he would always take uh he that's why
he starts that's why
well we know like what if like he
suffered from what have we heard joe coy
committed suicide we go no way we got to
investigate that
he's a happy get it dude you know
yeah what took so long he was always
kind of down man he
like he and i think when you do heroin
you're self-medicating that that's tim
i don't know that you do heroism shoot
yourself in the face because with that
that what's weird with that was the
amount of heroin in his body that's
where
we should all and also the the note was
actually to courtney cox the where they
said was the corner
courtney love jesus christ yeah thanks
for correcting that
the love was actually him saying he
doesn't want to be with her anymore it's
not a suicide note and they figured out
it's not his handwriting
the end part which is like i'm taking my
life i'm doing this they figure out that
yeah they say the writing's like yeah
they said that it doesn't match
just in case there's someone out there
that wants to kill us and make it look
like a suicide
we should all make a declaration of how
into life we are
yeah clyde would have killed himself
somebody's rich buddy in europe he's
playing out of europe
i want to drink some bordeaux i want to
live man
yeah if i do end up dead dude play this
i want to live
yeah fantastic i've i love katrina and
the waves
that's my favorite band i've been
treated for
walking my daughter down the aisle one
day
and uh you know the future is so bright
i got to wear shades man
oh anyone you find me dead yeah you know
what they're a self-inflicted
shotgun wound of a [ __ ] dead chicken
if somebody shoots a
chicken in my face we all have four die
by you see a
chicken cannon in my [ __ ] apartment i
didn't put it there
yeah if you see me on a roller coaster
at six flags and i die by [ __ ] a
frozen goose
know that there's no real frozen goose
out there someone [ __ ] killed me
somebody threw that somebody trained
that [ __ ]
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory right away you go bro
i figure out what you look like i'm like
what just run a bunch of other comics
i'm like what you're like
you look like a rottweiler we got a [ __ ]
together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son